zack snyder's justice league finally
premiered on
hbo max last week and fans have been
busy discussing and dissecting the film
in the days
since its debut it doesn't come as much
of a surprise that some of the biggest
and most noteworthy moments in the film
have to do with its nightmare sequences
the biggest nightmare sequence comes
during the epilogue and focuses on a
handful of players from the dc
eu the sequence sees the ragtag group
doing their best to sneak across
a hazy broken dystopian landscape which
looks to be the same one glimpsed
briefly during batman vs superman's
nightmare sequence
it's during the snyder cuts nightmare
scene that ben affleck's batman
has his first on-screen interaction with
jared leto's joker the conversation that
takes place between the two characters
not only takes up most of the scene's
run time but is also loaded with
references to other dceu films
and storylines for example he knows
exactly what it's like to lose someone
he loves
you know like a father like a mother
like an adopted son
isn't that right batman that's the line
spoken by joker that kicks off the
conversation between him and batman in
the film
the line references three of the moments
that proved to be the most formative for
the affleck version of batman
with the first two obviously being the
deaths of his father and mother the
third moment however
is one that has not been shown on screen
yet but was briefly referenced
during batman vs superman dawn of
justice the moment in question
is the death of robin batman's sidekick
and so-called
adopted son the character's death was
referenced when affleck's caped crusader
is seen
staring at a robin suit in a glass case
the words
ha ha jokes on you batman were seeing
spray painted onto the suit
heavily implying that the dceu's robin
had in fact
been killed by leto's joker while the
nightmare scene's
reference to robin is notable the
conversation between the two characters
doesn't end with
joker just throwing robin's death in
batman's face again
instead batman responds by referencing
the death of harley quinn
an event that hasn't happened on screen
yet and is implied to have occurred
sometime in between the present day
events of zack snyder's justice league
and the future shown in its final
nightmare sequence
batman describes how harley died in his
arms and with her last breath
demanded that he kill joker slowly a
request that bruce
says he still fully intends to fulfill
while it's unclear
why exactly harley wanted batman to kill
the joker
it's possible to infer given their
breakup in last year's birds of prey
that not even the end of the world could
manage to heal
harley and mr jay's relationship in the
dc eu
i am not someone who is love
i'm an idea one of the biggest ways
joker tries to emotionally manipulate
batman throughout the nightmare sequence
is referencing bruce's apparent role in
creating the dystopian future
joker says you need me to help you undo
this world you created by letting her
die
who is the her he's referencing none
other than lois lane
zack snyder has been candid about the
role lois lane's death was supposed to
play in his overall dc eu plans
essentially lois's death would have been
the thing that allowed darkseid to take
control of superman
and use him to bring about the ruined
world seen in justice league's nightmare
scenes
that means it's lois's body that
superman is seen holding during the
film's earlier nightmare sequence
and according to snyder lois death would
have been the result of batman failing
to sacrifice himself to save her
that's why the joker blames batman for
lois death and the apocalyptic scenario
as a whole but the most important part
of the scene is that it shows
two bitter enemies forced to work
together in the most extreme of
circumstances
regardless of their shared history and
the taunts they lob at each other
that's how dire the situation has become
things are so hopeless
that batman is willing to work with the
joker in order to defeat a superman gone
bad
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book moments are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]